as a company we have to focus we need to
find the right niche the right the right
place for us to
uh to make the the biggest impact uh
the you know a no-brainer thing that uh
we need that kind of a solution
and it has to be big enough welcome to
20 minute leaders just sit back relax
and learn from the leaders of today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with leumitech sponsored
by hippo insurance
opposed labs touring hillel at stanford
leap and in media partnership with ctec
welcome to another episode of 20 minute
leaders i'm being joined today by
michael shoham
the ceo of radix michael brings with him
more than 20 years of experience in
business development and deep
understanding of technology
he is passionate about technology sport
music and art
especially woodcraft and clay sculpture
michael holds a bsc from barline
university
and an mba from derby university he is a
loving husband married to mikhail a
psychotherapist
and a proud father of four daughters
michael shohem welcome to 20 minute
leaders
how are you today i'm great thank you
for having me here
hey thank you for coming i know how busy
you are and i really appreciate it
and we're going to talk about both your
own journey but also device management
and what you've been doing with radix
technologies now as the ceo you've held
multiple positions
coming more from a technical background
also with a bachelors of science and an
mba
and now you're you're leading the vision
for
radix technologies now when i say device
management there's a lot of ways to
interpret that
what do i mean when i say device
management in the context of radix
that's a great question because you know
this is a huge
topic it comes from
well it caters for everything from uh
the the little sensor on the on the
light bulb
uh all the way to uh um managing
um powerful computers but what we when
we're talking about
device management we're talking mainly
about uh
single purpose devices devices that are
used for specific
mission um and usually are android
driven
we we've noticed that
for the past around a decade um
things have been shifted from uh linux
based
single purpose devices to uh tried a
little bit of windows and then
um the majority of them today are
android and this is what we focus on we
focus on managing
any type of android device any type of
form factor it could be a vr device
a tablet a phone um you know even your
point of sale or mobile mobile point of
sale that is android doing today and
this is what we focus on
so what is the management piece of it
that you're when you're saying you're
managing you know you're attempting to
manage android devices
and you're talking a little bit about
the transition in the market what does
that actually mean management
well it depends on who you're asking who
is the who's the one that is actually
holding the device in hand and who is
the one that is on the other side of the
world so
uh our solution is a um a cloud-based
sas solution we deliver
um value for the entire life cycle of
of the device anyone that is in charge
of staging the device controlling it
uh in on a day-to-day uh cycle of uh
software software updates and
applications uh
security patches and and that sort of
thing
um all the way to um the customer
support and customer
care personnel that have uh their own
tools and their own
insights from our platform anything from
uh
remote remote control remote assistance
and all the way to top management that
gets insight and
uh ai driven uh insights from
uh device usage customer journey the way
that they're using the device itself
and also a learning about uh
things that can go wrong or did go wrong
and
some suggestions that how to fix it or
even automation and how to fix it so
everything um
is taken care of uh in a one single
point of uh
central management uh cloud-based
platform that that's what we do
so i think what will be very helpful for
me is if we can even go
back in a little bit higher and talk
about more higher level what is what
happened to the world where
we we reached a stage where people are
building their
there they have devices and they're
leveraging you know
well-known operating systems and they
need you know there is a gap in the
market where they need assistance to be
able to manage them
whether it be updates security patches
insights etc
right so i'll split the world into two
uh
one is the enterprise the day-to-day
enterprise business and there are plenty
of tools for that
uh there are solutions for uh keeping
your windows and macs and
ipads updated uh security patches uh
assistance policies and all that this is
the it
uh enterprise level applications uh but
there there is a whole
huge world of devices that are typically
not
in the hands of of a single person they
are called company-owned single-use
devices
uh these are the kosu company-owned
single-use
they can be in
kiosks around the world digital signage
on the wall things that don't have
someone that is specifically in charge
of
someone that is specifically using them
um and we've seen more and more devices
like this uh come into use um as i
mentioned
things like vr headsets they're roaming
around
uh with a different projects or
different uh
uh technology a lot a lot in healthcare
uh but nobody's
actually um managing them centrally
and they are uh left alone
or uh devices like uh um
your tab the tablet or the or the phone
of
a typical delivery person that is used
for that specific mission
it's locked down for that um
for that specific mission but there's no
but there's no
way uh to actually manage it because
it's outside your network it's outside
uh
the scope of the i.t person uh that can
um help in one on that day-to-day
uh use case um we came from
a little niche called education we
started from
from that point where there are uh
millions of students holding devices in
their hand they're a single mission
for using them in uh in a specific
uh form of uh of um
you know a lockdown device for education
and spread out for
um other verticals as well but this is
where we came from and this is uh
uh where we encountered this uh first
time
right and so you know i i remember
you know being in middle school and then
having and getting a laptop from the
school and i remember that it always
fascinated me to understand
to what extent are do they are they able
to even to know anything about what's
happening on the device not not not from
a privacy concern
really from a technologically curious
concern and paint me a picture
what what how big is this is this issue
or this opportunity today
how many devices around the world do we
have that say that are running android
tv or or
or windows or whatever operating system
it may be
so i'm i don't have the exact number of
devices for
that that are running windows but
they're according to researchers there
are going to be about
uh 24 billion uh smart devices around
the world so these 24 billion devices
uh some of them are in enterprises some
of them are home
usage uh some of them were for you know
um personal use
uh but most of them are uh company owned
uh even uh the um vertical that we're
focusing today on and which
you mentioned android tv uh these
devices are used
for personal entertainment but they are
owned by the telecom companies
uh there are millions and millions of
devices android tv devices out there
uh that require uh central management so
there are some tools
uh historical tools that are used for
managing them uh
but they're not built for android
they're not able to
uh to utilize the the power
of that computing device these tools
were built for managing
your home router these are not smart
uh devices they are dumb devices they
are very static they're not
they're not intended to uh to be changed
too much there are some patches here and
there
uh and some require some some assistance
is required but today when
uh telcos introduce android tv and
the the device that they deliver to uh
to your home
is a very powerful computing device
which would
that has a lot of capabilities you can
install your own application
site load application and whoever is in
charge is still the telecom company so
you are
actually um opening that
world and and bringing it into your
house
without anyone taking care of it and
this is what we're uh we're bringing
along
uh the ability for the technical support
uh personnel to
understand what's happening on your
device when you allow them you said
person uh you said
uh privacy privacy is uh top concern but
of course after we pass that
uh we still need to be able to assist in
real time we still need to be able to
uh get some analytics and understand
what's happening on these million
devices out there
uh even if it's completely anonymous but
it's still something that we have
um and and we need to know what's uh
what's happening what's going on so when
we're saying device management
it's not uh your uh typical remote
installation or
or technical uh technical support it's
everything everything around that
specific device
right i think one of the most you know
amazing things that i'm that i'm
thinking of
you know previously if you had if you
were asking me about device management
let's say five six years ago i would say
yes it's for remote access so that
somebody so that i can help my
grandmother
download skype and teach how to use it
but today you know with
updates needing to be needing to take
place you know every day every day
there's
something else there's new opportunities
there's no use cases let's say you
deploy
you know on on on a hundred thousand
devices now you wanna install an
application on them
which is complementary to another one
that you have right i mean i'm these are
the world is you know as the software is
eating the world
we're seeing a shift where things need
to be updated constantly and it sounds
like this is one of the main use cases
right
right correct this is one of the main
use cases from a couple of different
angles so if we're
talking about android tv uh
traditionally the way that
these boxes or these set of boxes were
were uh
updated is once in a while there was a
an oda
over there update over their firmware
update with all the little patches and
changes and updates and applications
that were
uh that that the telcom company decided
to update that could have been
um once a year twice a year or something
like that
um and that was great when it was
talking when when we were talking about
a satellite receiver or or a cable
receiver which is really static
nothing really to change uh but today
even a a small application that is
in breach of uh um security or drm
or uh or private or privacy that there
are
issues that cannot wait for that
once a year or twice a year update these
have to be pushed out
actively and you have to know that
things like that happen and if you don't
know that if you're
completely blind into what happens uh on
[Music]
on your customers devices sometimes it's
a bit
too late uh to to to react or it's going
to take too much time
to response to a catastrophe so
of course we're not always talking about
catastrophes but we're talking about a
day-to-day
updates and uh applications that
uh can be very useful for
for a typical customer is um
a real big issue for a telecom company
take kodi for example it's a
legit application right you can use it
um you can
play movies that you have the rights to
play them you can uh
watch shows or or or streams that are
but what happens if someone is using it
for uh stream
streaming uh piracy is the telecom
company
uh in charge of that are they um
are they going to take the hit for that
so they have to know that something like
that is happening
even if it's completely anonymous they
have to put some rules around that
and we have the tools to allow them uh
to respond
uh to respond or even to prevent things
like that in in the first place
so again this is not a typical use case
for
um remote management but that's it
that's part of the
part of the capabilities right and it
sounds to me like that part of the game
here is being able to provide a solution
for
for all these edge cases that you know
you need to you know you need to
do something you don't necessarily know
what if now i got a message that i might
that all the kiosk portages in
california need to be recalled that i
need to figure out how to send
the car to the mechanic to fix something
in the software right
and it was pretty crazy and i'm thinking
you know obviously it would be much much
better if they can
and for them especially if they can just
send a software update to the hundred
thousand cars that they sold in the
region
without having to now coordinate with
these mechanics which are
you know in our analogy they're more
about the software people
right yeah i think the the bottom line
for telecom companies is to
reduce customer charts or they they
won't you know they won't leave them to
someone else
and also to reduce the truck rolls uh
you can't dispatch a technician every
time someone doesn't really know how to
do that so we have that
remote set of tools but the main the
main
customer for us or the main partner for
us is the device manufacturer they are
the ones that
um we work closely with we uh
um no matter what's vertical no matter
where it is even uh
uh the big screen that i have behind me
on the wall this is a uh
a smart touch enabled uh device it's
like a huge tablet on the wall
we work with these manufacturers to
include our device management
as part of the firmware as part of the
device when it rolls out of the
of the factory this is the point of time
where uh
it's best to engage with remote
management because it's persistent
it's part of the firmware it will be
there all the time it has the lowest
or or the um the highest level of access
to the device itself
and it's in the best of interest of both
the
manufacturers and their customers that
it will come
directly from the manufacturer so we do
a lot of uh oem white labeling with uh
the top leading vendors like uh foxconn
sharp
fujitsu um and you know the likes of
them
um and i think that uh this is
around 80 of our of our business working
with these manufacturers to include our
solutions
um out of the factory so it's really
really stealth it's down there it's it's
in your it's in your device it it can be
completely dormant
but when um someone needs to use it they
can uh
they can wake it up and use it so
yeah it's uh it's not it's not a
security
um element it's not an antivirus or or a
firewall
it's not a um it's
it's something that is there and when
you need it you should know that
that the you as the manufacturer can use
it
uh to to update these uh these millions
of devices that you have out there
very very cool and so tell me a little
bit about the vision you're also
focusing on android tv
i'd love to hear a little bit about that
yeah so um
we as a platform we are able to
manage as i said almost every type of
device any type of uh
operating system can be ios windows
chrome
linux but as a company we have to focus
we need to find the right niche the
right the right place for us to
uh to make the the biggest impact uh
the you know a no-brainer thing that we
need that kind of a solution
and it has to be big enough so um we uh
uh we found that the android tv market
is
one of the fastest growing uh device
driving
platforms uh around the world of course
you can you you can install
uh netflix on your phone but uh
the telco the telecom companies will uh
prefer to send you a small set of box
and that is today um mostly android
driven
android tv in specific um and we found
that uh
uh the the tools that they're using
today are
completely off they're they're not the
right ones they're not
the uh the solutions that they actually
need
uh because they came from a completely
different scope
as i mentioned managing uh using
legacy protocols to manage uh
a home router will not do and will not
be uh sufficient to manage android tv so
we're
uh partnering up with android tv
manufacturers we're working with google
uh and we're also uh uh
working with the with the telecom
companies uh in order to
deliver that kind of uh of uh support
and that kind of uh
um capability or or set of tools for
for this huge and rapidly
growing uh vertical and uh so far we're
uh we're getting a you know unbelievable
traction we uh just launched this
officially the beginning of 2021
and we're now working with almost 70
percent of the
of the the global manufacturers for uh
the set of box manufacturers
um either with business partnerships and
or even uh
they recommend our solution to their
customers mainly telcos so this is what
we're focusing right now and this is
where we're growing this
uh but as a platform it's it's you know
it's a platform it can grow
um next you know next stage can be um
something else but right now this is the
main focus for the company
very cool you see 500 episodes i think i
must have had at least 100 guests that
are building products that
that would need that could leverage this
and and i just love
the fight that i'm getting exposed to to
all these types of verticals and domains
and problems that i did and i haven't
stopped to think about this problem in
the last few years
and and obviously it makes perfect sense
and it's just you know the market is
exploding and it's going to become
bigger and bigger and more and more
complicated
and and solutions that previously
companies were able to mitigate through
sending technicians at the scale that
the world operates today it just doesn't
work like that
and and it's it's not going to work for
them yeah without going
too much into uh into the technicalities
uh there are enterprise solutions uh
lots of them anyway anyone that uh
is a part of a big enterprise know that
there's someone managing their device
but this is not the right tool for uh
for solutions like uh android tv or
single purpose devices
in other scopes and other spares uh
a lot a lot to do with the protocols a
lot to do with uh the ecosystem around
enterprise devices
which are completely different when it's
coming to vanilla android or android tv
or things that are not
uh purposeful for enterprises um
google emm is not present there so i
have a few fun questions
quick fun questions about you my client
i wanted to talk about
you as an artist and clay and what
you're doing there and the philosophy
behind it
we're gonna have to leave that to
another episode the other the rest was
just too interesting
uh but i have a few questions about you
and i'm gonna take you back to your
childhood
what fascinated you as a kid what was
your either favorite subject in school
a passion hobby so school wasn't really
a big thing for me but uh
the what always fascinated me was uh
computers i
i uh started at a very very uh
a small age um and i think i grew into
this company
uh from you know after my vomit
something like that this is
really uh a a long time i'm
i'm a veteran in this uh in this
specific company of course we
changed and shifted and and uh and you
know
we did a lot of changes around uh
but uh i i grew into this company
[Music]
very very cool a a role model somebody
that inspires you
along the way so um it changed
uh it used to be uh bill gates you know
this is uh
a person that um anyone that
well you could have either loved him or
hated him
uh at some point i really uh admired
what he did
uh i think that uh it kind of changed
around uh the past uh
in the past couple of years but uh um in
terms of building a company building a
product
uh taking something that uh was already
there but making it much bigger
or this is something that i admired
very very cool and three words that you
would use to describe yourself
um very caring
this is i think uh one of the
uh one of the top things that i can say
about myself that i
i care about uh things that are
happening around me
uh in terms of people uh the
the company our customers i think that
uh
that that really describes me uh i think
that i am um
a creative thinker i have a lot i i
think a little bit differently than uh
what the people around me uh
or the different from people around me
and this is why it's great to have such
a talent
a talented group of people around me
that will always
bring me back into uh into focus
um well i i don't know what will be the
third one but i think that
this is that this kind of covers
a lot of a lot of brand i'll take it
michael tadagaba thank you very very
much best of luck with alex technologies
and i look forward to keep on following
and being a fan and thank you for your
time
thank you bye take care